السلام عليكم ورحمه الله هذا موجز الاخبار
من الجزيره عقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه
مغلقه بحث خلال هالاوضاع المتوتره في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله واتفق الاعضاء
على متابعه الوضع عن كثب وبحث سبل دعم
الحوار ووقف العنف
قال المندوب الفلسطيني لدى الامم المتحده
رياض منصورنا الوقت حان لان يتحمل مجلس
الامن الدولي مسؤوليته بتوفير الحمايه
للسكان المدنيين الفلسطينيين
هذا وقال جون كيربي منسق والاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه بمجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
للجزيره ان الاحداث الكارثيه التي شهدتها
الضفه الغربيه تؤكد اهميه الالتزام
بالتفاهمات المعلنه في العقبه
دعت وزاره الخارجيه التونسيه البعثات
الدبلوماسيه في البلاد الى عدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه لتونس وقالت الوزاره ان
تونس حريصه على تسهيل عمل البعثات
الدبلوماسيه مع التقيد بمقتضيات اتفاقيه
فيينا التي تنص على عدم التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه
كما قالت المتحدثه باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي
للشؤون الخارجيه الى الاتحاد يتابع بقلق
بالغ من الوضع في تونس فان هذا الامر ستتم
مناقشته في اجتماع وزراء خليجيته الاتحاد
الشهر المقبل
قال بيان لهيئه الدفاع عن السياسيين
الموقوفين فيما عرف بملف التعامل على امن
الدوله ان الموقوفين حملوهم رساله الى
الراي العام يعبرون فيها عن ادانتهم
الانتهاكات التي تعرضوا لها ويرفضون ما
تعمل اليه سلطه الرئيس قيس سعيد التي
وصفوها بالانقلابيه
اكد تقرير للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
ان الوكاله تجري نقاشا مع ايران بشان
جزيئاته يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه
83.7% في منشاه فوردو وهي نسبه قريبه جدا
من درجه النقاء المطلوبه لصنع الاسلحه
النوويه
قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انه يجب ان
لا تمتلك ايرانو قنبله نوويه فان هذا هو
موقف مشترك بين المانيا واسرائيل واضافت
الوزيره عقب لقائها مع نظيرها الاسرائيلي
ببرلين ان البلدين يشعران بقلق اذا
التصعيد النووي الايراني
وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
في خطوط الجبهه بانها تزداد شراسه وقال ان
المواجهات في باخموت الشرقيه البلاد هي
الاشد
من جانبها قالت ميليشيا فاجنر انها تتقدم
على الطقوم الشماليه لمدينه بخموت وسيطرت
بالكامل على حي ستوبكي شمل غربي المدينه
اشكركم على متابعتي هذا الموز طابت
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]